welcome back everybody to the david
pakman show luke beasley here filling in
for david while he is away don't forget
to check out my youtube luke beasley on
youtube or luke beasley on any podcast
listening platform if you are a listener
there was a texas gop convention over
the weekend where a number of notable
things happened one of the big takeaways
from a couple of these moments is that
the far right
isn't
far right enough for the extreme
you know radical right wingers that are
becoming more prominent so what i'm
talking about is dan crenshaw was
walking through an event and got
aggressively accosted by some right
wingers not liberals we're not the
left's not going after him it's
these far far right people going after
dan crenshaw
calling him a rhino republican in name
only let's take a look at this video and
then we'll discuss
i patch mccain hey i patch mckay look at
i passed mccain right here you're rhino
you're so blessed you're globalist right
now
[Music]
and red flag laws too dad that's
ridiculous
hey dan why are you on the world
economic forum young global leaders
world economic forum young global leader
hey dan what's clash woah's number you
got clash royale's number one
so they're screaming at him calling him
a globalist rhino again that's
republican in name only and usually
people call
uh
other republicans rhinos if they're not
pro-trump enough or far-right enough and
then they also were calling him eye
patch mccain which is a
term tucker carlson coined which is
bizarre why i never understand stop
going after people's physical features
just go after their positions their
policies that's it
it's crazy or they're you know lack of
principles whatever it is anything
that's not physical appearance related
or the fact that he's you know has
damage to one of his eyes
um
you could see it seemed to escalate to
actual violence i couldn't quite tell
with that video
what
happened but from the reporting as well
as what you could hear in the video it
looked like something really got
physical besides just them kind of
pressing up
um and then i guess one of the guys was
very upset that dan crenshaw is involved
in the world economic forum which i know
very little about but klaus schwab he
kept saying is the founder of it
i don't know what his deal is with all
of that but the crazy thing is dan
crenshaw is very pro-trump and he's very
conservative but he just barely sort of
critiqued trump and wasn't the most you
know outspoken the election was stolen
person he kind of avoided that question
and then he supports red flag laws was
one of the things they brought up
and that's what you're angry about that
tiny little difference between trump and
him and between you and him he's a
conservative guy and they're still not
happy with them it's crazy because their
actual policy differences are so tiny
it just they you know dan crenshaw
doesn't appear radical enough for their
liking
because if you think about democrats
aoc and joe manchin the difference
between the difference between those two
people is
way larger than any republicans
in their policy differences and yet
leftists aren't going out and accosting
joe manchin
like that
in the spirit of this at the same texas
event ted cruz got made fun of uh for
being a trump bootlicker but
in a contradictory way you know he first
criticized trump a lot on the campaign
trail and trump alluded to his wife
being ugly and his dad may have caused
you know done 9 11.
ted cruz like you don't talk about my
family like that um so against you and
then trump wins the nomination and ted
cruz
so a guy walked up he's not the hero
but he makes correct points let's take a
look america you know that remember how
trump made fun of your wife and then you
go become best friends and trust you i
know but why do you do that you go
become best friends with trump after he
makes fun of you and your wife why do
you do that i i understand you don't
want to because you're texting you don't
want to see i do love america so you
don't you care more about the border
between uh ukraine and russia and you
care about the border between texas and
mexico why is that
why do you care about government i know
but why are you globalist you're a
globalist but you know it ted hey teddy
you're good
you're a globalist ted you know that bud
and that's why you're a coward and a
liar and you know that and i know that
and that's why you're afraid to stand up
for when people were freezing and dying
you were in cancun mexico you remember
that you remember when you're at the
all-inclusive buffet why people were
freezing no but do you remember that ted
when everybody was freezing remember
that when people were dying
so like i said
that guy is low off his rocker if you
ever hear someone use the term globalist
or as david pakman says uh impersonating
alex jones globalish
um
most the time i guess you could use that
term if you meant like someone who's
pro-globalization a globalist or like
pro
there could be an okay usage of that
word definitionally but the way that
it's used in politics is almost always
super conspiratorial and an indication
that someone's a little
but the points he was making besides
that weren't wrong right i mean
it can't be forgotten that ted cruz
kissed up to donald trump after
trump alluded to his wife being ugly
oh maybe his dad did 9 11 is what trump
was
spouting off about and ted was so brave
at that point characterizing trump is
such a terrible candidate
and then trump won the nomination and
ted cruz is the biggest bootlicker
and then also it shouldn't be forgotten
as that guy pointed out that texas was
in that big freeze and texans are or
were suffering
and he flew off to cancun and then
blamed it on his daughters that was so
so weird uh this is a complete side note
but during that freeze because it's
popped up this is a crazy cute story
at that point my family we were all here
and we had
12 puppies
not my entire family wasn't here but i
was here sister parents and we had 12
puppies golden retriever puppies from a
golden retriever that we had and or we
still have and these 12 puppies
were at like
little
weeks old and so whenever the freeze
happened all the power went out and
if they stayed out in our house when it
got that cold they would all have died
luckily we had one little space heater
so we packed in this tiny little room
use the space heater to keep the puppies
alive it was wild and during all of that
instead of ted cruz coming and helping
us with our puppies no he could have
helped other people um he was off in
cancun living up
the good life
so
he's a goofball the guy who walked up to
ted cruz but so is ted cruz so he kind
of deserves it and the points he was
making we're definitely correct
and i love how ted cruz's reaction is
always just completely not address what
they're saying he was he kept saying
like oh i know you you don't love texas
or you don't want to defend texas okay
yeah sure ted
one of our sponsors is magic spoon the
only breakfast cereal that tastes
exactly like your favorite sugary
childhood cereals but with zero sugar
only four net carbs and 14 grams of
protein so if you're just generally
trying to keep your sugar intake
relatively low like me or if you're
doing low carb if you're doing keto you
can enjoy the sweet nostalgic snack
without the sugar in flavors like cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter cookies and
cream maple waffle blueberry cinnamon
they've just added honey nut to their
permanent collection i love magic spoon
our whole team does and they've been
supporting the show for years
how about this if you try magic spoon
and you don't think it's amazing like we
do they'll give you your money back
because magic spoon stands behind their
product because it's that good you
really can't tell it apart from the
classic cereals build your own custom
variety pack you'll get five dollars off
when you go to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman the
link is in the description